great well thanks bad appreciate the
setup in the intro and thanks everyone
for joining us here today we're going to
be driving into what I find an extremely
exciting topic and that is the topic of
content marketing and it's really that
heart and soul of both inbound and
outbound demand creation so let's just
do some level setting first and talk
first about demand creation and to get
us started want to share with you one of
my favorites this is an oldie this is
actually from an advertisement that was
put out by mcgraw-hill Publishing when
they were trying to get people to really
think about advertising but I just think
it captures so much about what we're
trying to do with demand creation I
don't know who you are I don't know your
company I don't know your company's
product I don't know what your company
stands for I don't know your company's
customers I don't know your company's
record I don't know your company's
reputation now what was it you wanted to
sell me which really is a tee up for
something that we think about a lot in
the marketing arena which is the
hierarchy of effects essentially our job
and demand creation is to move people
through this hierarchy of effects
starting with folks who are totally
unaware of the product or unaware of the
company getting Tim to that stage where
they have general awareness taking them
then to the stage where they have
knowledge about what we have to offer
from knowledge we go to liking from
liking we take them into preference so
they have a greater desire to buy from
us than someone else to where they have
a strong conviction to actually do
something purchase another way of
thinking about this or simpler way
perhaps is demand creation is about
creating that umbrella of awareness
driving through to giving people that
reason that they should consider us
versus anything else out there and to
finally where they're really starting to
look at doing something or driving
action for folks that may be involved in
a more sales oriented function or a
company that is very focused on sales
the other way we look at this is called
the funnel it's exact same thing it's
about creating that awareness with
activities above the funnel it's about
using active
to move a prospect through the funnel
getting them through those consideration
stages to finally where they take an
action which is where sales comes in so
this whole construct when we think about
content marketing it plays a very
pivotal role in getting people through
that hierarchy of effects or in more of
a sales vernacular getting people
through that sales funnel and with the
rise of everything that's going on in
terms of the internet we are not in a
world that is lacking for information
we've really ended up in a place where
there is a tremendous amount of
information or information abundance and
the problem that information abundance
creates quite frankly is this idea of
attention scarcity this is all what
they're now calling attention economics
the attention economy is not growing
which means we have to grab the
attention that someone else has today in
short the role of demand creation has
never been more important we're trying
to grab that attention that is out there
and content marketing ends up being just
a super tool for us to use so when we
think of demand creation we should also
consider that there are two types of
demand creation I mentioned this right
up front there's both the inbound and
the outbound types of demand creation
inbound is really about strategies and
tactics that are pulling prospective
customers to you you're helping them
find you found marketing's about
strategy and tactics that push the
prospective customers or in other words
you're finding them the upside quite
frankly of inbound is chances are you're
getting more qualified leads because
people are seeking you out there trying
to find you and potentially there's a
lower cost of sales because they're
helping themselves to those original
stages of awareness and consideration
the downside is prospects have to be
absolutely engaged in searching for you
or they won't find you so you've got to
make sure that the word is out there and
you may get a lot of people that really
aren't within your target audience again
they're finding you you don't have a
choice
on the opposite side talking about out
loud the upside is your
actually identifying the specific people
that you want to go after and you're
creating potentially business
development type opportunities the
downside is a lot of people distress
have distrust in this whole idea of
outbound marketing or you pushing
yourself upon them so when you're
creating a demand creation program when
you're bringing content marketing into
that program important to think about
having a blend of both of those and when
you think about the vehicles that we
have available to us as marketers on the
inbound side you have things like blogs
podcasts videos ebooks enewsletter
all vehicles that are drawing people to
you on the outbound side what we think
of as more classically traditional
marketing is about public relations
analyst relations advertising Direct
Mail email marketing you can read down
the list now caveat some people might
argue that things like PR are actually
vehicles to draw people to you the
reason why we put them into the outbound
category is because you're still pushing
your own message out you're still really
driving to find them so in this universe
of inbound and outbound demand creation
you want to have a good blend of both
and when it comes to content marketing
what you really start noticing it is a
lot of it really is about inbound
it's the blogs it's the podcasts it's
the video the ebooks white papers
e-newsletters it's about things that
have super interesting content and
content marketing also does play a role
in outbound as I mentioned earlier
because it becomes the vehicle to draw
people so if you have a lead generation
program maybe you send out an email and
you say hey we'd love for you to have
this white paper click here and give us
information that's how it would factor
into the outbound side the content
marketing has a lot to do with those
inbound vehicles that we were looking at
so kind of a really short synopsis about
what demand creation is this role of
inbound and outbound vehicles how we
blend them use them balance them and
where content marketing really starts
fitting in that mix so what is content
Marketing well there are a lot of
different definitions out there
researched a bunch of them but this is
the one that resonated the most with me
content marketing is the process for
developing executing and delivering the
content and related assets that are
needed to create nurture and grow a
company's customer base again think
about that hierarchy of effects we
address at the very beginning it's this
idea of awareness consideration and then
finally moving into action and content
marketing can play a role in each of
those areas
so why content marking why all of a
sudden are people getting really excited
about this is almost its own area of
marketing let's start out with an
inside-out point of view by inside-out I
mean it's about the company thinking
about itself thinking about what's going
on why something's valuable some great
statistics here twenty seven million
pieces of content are shared every day
people are out there they find the
content interesting they're actually
sending it out to colleagues friends
others that they think might have an
interest in it people spend more than
50% of their time online reading content
with an additional 30% on social media
people are engaged this is where their
interests are clicks from shared content
are five times more likely to result in
purchase and content marketing generates
three times more leads per dollar than
traditional advertising so it is a very
appealing tool for a company to use in
trying to win business out in the market
but what's always important to me is
that we balance it with an outside-in
point of view by that we mean how are
customers thinking about things how is
that target audience we're trying to
reach thinking about the picture here
are another couple of great statistics
70% of consumers say content marketing
makes them feel closer to the sponsoring
company
and 58% of online consumers trust the
content as opposed to very few people
who trust traditional advertising
content so really good reasons of why
doing content marketing from a
customer's perspective it's something
that they're really interested in it's
something that they see brings value by
the way that's a cardinal rule here in
the whole content marketing world it's
not about advertising stories it's not
about pushing all your features and your
benefits and why you're better than
anyone else out there it's about
providing truly relevant truly useful
content and if you're still skeptical
about should we be investing in content
marketing is this something that my
company should be getting more involved
in well here's another statistic I
thought might be useful to you content
marketing is taking center stage 63% of
marketers plan to increase their
spending on content that they're
providing out to their consumers to
their users to their customers and when
you think about this this is just a b2b
phenomenon a b2c phenomenon well that
statistic of 63% is an average when you
think about b2b they're going to be
investing six at 69% while b2c at 53% so
this is a tool that you're seeing both
in business-to-business b2b companies as
well as business-to-consumer b2c
companies and very few people are
decreasing their spend which should be
another reason why you think about it
once or twice alright so now that we're
grounded in what demand creation is
about and what essentially content
marketing is about let's talk about how
we go do this so take a strategic
approach it always starts with thinking
about what the objectives are so top
objectives of content marketing lead
generation which is again more of that
outbound demand creation push thought
leadership and market education brand
awareness and preference again hierarchy
of effects creating that awareness
creating that consideration which is
about developing preference and a very
tactical objectives SEO
optimization great tool for being able
to do that now I had said earlier that
content is important to outbound and
that there's a slight difference there
let me just get a little more specific
the reality is when you use content
marketing in an inbound sense you're
giving it away for free you're sharing
it it's it's something you want people
to get interested in so they eventually
come and find you
when you're using content is a part of
an outbound marketing campaign you want
to get something in return and
traditionally what you'll do is put that
content behind what we call a lead wall
talk a little bit more about that in a
couple of minutes but you're asking for
information about them so you can reach
out to them so that's kind of that
difference between lead generation and
pure thought leadership and brand
awareness and lead generation part of
the outbound world you're actually
looking for something in return and
coming to that point of lead generation
it's probably is no surprise that is one
of the number one drivers for people
doing content you see here about 59% of
people use content for lead generation
it's one of those things that you have
to give and that give to get
relationship with prospects and people
you're trying to have become leads and
when you think about content as an offer
it has so many other opportunities going
back to those objectives like creating
that thought leadership creating that
brand preference around what you have to
say all right now let's go back over to
that discussion of lead walls again big
difference between having it out there
for inbound marketing versus outbound
marketing is an outbound marketing you
want something in return for giving that
content out and traditionally well what
you'll see is that lead wall is living
on your website so you create a landing
page for that specific campaign so maybe
you send someone an email maybe it's a
link in a newsletter and you say hey
would love for you to have this content
I think it's going to be super useful to
you you direct them to a landing page on
your site and then from there you have
them register you ask them for that key
information and essentially that's where
the wall construct comes in you don't
get the content unless I get information
from you and there are different ways of
gathering information you can ask for
just a couple of simple things just the
bare minimums of what you need to know
maybe a name and an email address name
and a telephone number or you can go to
a long lead form you're actually asking
for some additional details that help
you qualify that candidate it shouldn't
be surprising you'll see the statistics
they're shorter does better we are all
very private people the less information
we have to give the better and what they
have also seen happen is when you go to
that longer form and you require people
to provide that information oftentimes
because of privacy reasons they'll hold
that giving you the true information so
you have to question whether you're
really getting that much useful
information about going long so one of
the things to think about is you're
putting a content program together is
are you just going to give it out freely
as an inbound marketing effort or are
you actually going to require some
information making it more part of a
lead generation outbound campaign and
when you do this how much information
are you going to ask for in return so
let's talk about the process when I read
that definition of content marketing I
try to highlight the word process
because it really is about having a
process and here are five steps that I
commonly use and then there's a secret
sixth one I'll also mention but the
first step is defining your audience you
have to learn what they're interested
again taking that outside in perspective
standing in the shoes of your customers
and really learning what it is that
would attract them that would make them
want to find you second thing I do is I
look at the market I research what
others are developing on that particular
area what topics are interesting to them
do that for two reasons one I don't want
to duplicate it I want to have the
original content that out there is that
I want to have original content out
there because that's going to benefit my
thought leadership my image in the
market but I also want to see what
others are writing about out there
because it may spur additional ideas
maybe they've talked about a topic but
they haven't gone all the way with it I
also do a little inventory internally
once I've decided okay this is an area
that I want to create
around uncle and find out what we
already have as an organization
sometimes there's things that have been
written and put aside diagrams that have
been put together by say an engineering
team that are all assets that I can
leverage and it makes it faster and
quicker to put the content together then
you define what is that actual strategy
going to look like and I'm going to give
you a framework for how you put that
together but then you decide what is the
content you're going to produce when
you're going to produce it step 5
pretty obvious creating the assets
getting that content all together and
then the secret one which we'll also
talk about is number six which is
distribution does no good to have
content and not actually get it out into
the market so five-step process very
simple just very easy to be able to get
that content marketing program together
it's also important to think about what
are the roles in content marketing so
may seem pretty obvious but sometimes
people will forget there are certain
roles that actually are pretty critical
to having successful content so the
first role is the writer and probably
very obvious they're responsible for
authoring the story authoring the
content you're putting together you've
got the editor and these are the people
that are actually refining it they're
making the story better
by the way shorter is always better
tightening that story up having it
really get to the key messages super
critical the designer is the person
that's responsible for the layout and
the look of the finished content the
distributor comes to kind of secret step
in the process number six getting the
content out there and then finally the
publisher is the person who takes
responsibility for making sure that
there's access to that content say on a
website or a third party site now don't
get scared
you don't have to have all these roles
in one team now some companies do
they're large enough they're investing
enough in this that they'll go ahead and
have these very distinct roles actually
on their team and actually 47% of
marketers have a dedicated content team
the other configuration you'll see is
people have multiple roles
maybe the writer is also the distributor
maybe the editor is also the designer so
you can load up on the roles and then
also you can use other people in your
company
to step in and assist with different
parts of this but important to think
through those roles if you just write it
distribute it chances are it won't have
the quality that it would have you had
an editor involved and you actually took
some time to design it and give it that
look and feel so here's a framework or a
template for building that content
strategy going back to that step number
four that we spoke about and again very
simple tool identify who your target
audiences are because you want to write
for them what are the primary objectives
why are you creating this content and
then putting together that more tactical
content production calendar and the
reason it's important to get this down
in paper is this isn't a one of people
will actually think of content as a one
up I got this great white paper let's
get it out there what you really want to
think about is this as a very holistic
process a holistic plan that addresses
the needs of the business and they have
found that companies with these
documented content strategies are going
to be much more effective in what
they're doing in content marketing so
don't make it a random act of content go
ahead and really put it out there and
when we said content types we looked at
look at this when we looked at the
inbound and outbound vehicles as well
but really it is about white papers case
studies cheat sheets things with tricks
and tips on them checklists that might
be useful to someone when considering a
topic webinars podcasts ebooks this
includes things like reference guides
and workbooks enews letters videos blog
posts infographics remember we're all
very image driven cartoons comics so
lots of different opportunities to
create content and if you get stuck go
out there and look at what other people
are doing there are some companies that
have really done a great job these are
some of my personal favorites I actually
regularly register to get their content
because I think they do such a good job
of it but companies like HubSpot
companies like el agua Pixability doing
a lovely job with putting together
content marketing so go out there and
look see what other people are doing to
be able to really help you think about
your own strategy so when we think of
sources of content there really are four
primary ones first one is creative
content this is really about what you
create yourself what you and your team
develop in-house the second is crowd
sourced you'd be amazed at how many
people are willing to help you to create
content either something that you bundle
together as a created piece or as
content they just want to offer up
customers great resource for this there
are best practices there are tips and
tricks on how they did something there's
also the idea of curated content I'm a
big fan of this personally this is where
someone else goes and does the hard work
for you as a consumer they go out and
look at all the available content that's
been written out there and they put it
together and say hey here are five
articles you as a CMO should read this
week so you can curate other people's
content have to be honest about it can't
adopt it as your own but you can put it
out there and you're doing the work form
and finally the idea of syndicated
content this is really where you're
leasing content that someone else has
written great example of that our
industry analysts they'll put a report
together on your industry on your
company and then you essentially lease
it or buy the rights to be able to put
it out there on the market so there are
different sources to get your content
you don't have to just do all the
writing yourself so something to think
about all right so now you've got a
strategy you've figured out the types of
content you're going to put together you
figured out where they're going to come
from now let's really make sure that we
get into a little bit of making that
content really effective and headlines
do make a difference
the reason they make a difference is 80%
of readers don't make it past the
headline so if your headline isn't going
to grab their attention chances are
you're not going to get your content
registered for or downloaded or accessed
and traffic can vary up to five hundred
percent based on that headline does that
headline appeal to the audience that I'm
really trying to get to does it really
get to the folks that are going to make
a difference in my business so headlines
matter which means learning a little bit
about copywriting can go
Longway and these are a few of the
techniques from the American writers and
artists Institute and it's an approach
that I have actively looked at and
leveraged so make sure that you can be
useful to the reader so when you're
writing that headline make sure that
it's something that the reader can zero
in on and say yes this is content that I
want providing them with a sense of
urgency you can do this with things like
five steps you can't miss by tomorrow
really making sure that they see that
this is something they shouldn't just
give some day I'll go find that content
that it's something they want to read
now convey the idea that the main
benefit is somehow unique that your
content isn't something they've already
read because again remember they're
getting bombarded by a lot of different
sources of information out there and
then finally do all the above in a very
ultra specific way that will assist them
alright another question that comes up a
lot as well how often do I have to
produce content yeah I do I do it once a
year once a month well again there is no
set rule my guideline is know your
audience find the right balance because
if you put too much out there people
will just turn it off make sure it's the
right balance of types of content
because again people may get bored if
it's always a white paper coming out and
then go for quality over quantity again
this isn't a race to the end of how many
pieces of content can I develop this is
about really finding content that's
going to resonate with your audience
we'll talk again about that at a moment
so how often here are some statistics I
thought you might find interesting
38% of marketers publish content weekly
or more often 42% of the aliquot
community marketers produce at least one
piece of content per week b2b marketers
publish new content 16% daily 26%
multiple times per week
17% weekly 19% multiple times per month
so you start seeing that kind of that
weekly theme is coming into there but
again it's about knowing your audience
and making sure that you can produce the
right quality content
all right secret rule number six of the
process you gotta distribute it it does
no good just to have content you have to
think about how you're actually going to
market the content and interestingly
content marketers use traditional
outbound demand creation vehicles to get
their content out in the market here are
some of the more popular ones social
media putting it in a link perhaps it's
in a tweet perhaps it's out there on one
of your pages paid search making sure
that people know that it's out there
through that vehicle display ads
offering up perhaps the display at its
place in a publication you know that
your audience wants to get to and
they're going through that publication
on regular basis you can advertise there
let them know you've got some great
content in addition to what's in the
publication search out search engine
optimization seo obviously clear email
that becomes really more part of the
lead distribution or lead generation
type process syndication finding other
people this is using syndication to
distribute finding other people that
will put your content out there for you
and then usually there's an arrangement
that perhaps for every time someone
downloads the content you pay them a
small fee and then finally content
recommendation platform so think about
the tactics you're going to use as well
so you have to go through that full
end-to-end process alright so what makes
content ineffective well we already
talked about the headline is important
because you got to grab that attention
you got get them in but what most people
will say is it really is about audience
relevance this gets back to that quality
point it gets back to knowing your
audience thinking outside in if it's
relevant and it's something that's going
to make a difference to them personally
either in their work life or their
personal life you're going to have a
homerun
you're going to make that breakthrough
it has to be compelling and engaging
make sure you write it well if you have
a great topic but it's not written well
again you're going to lose the audience
in the process and what else makes it
effective it triggers some type of a
response or action that maybe just them
sharing it with someone else or maybe
them coming back to your company and
saying I'd love to
more about what you have to offer so
think about what makes content effective
and that will make your program more
effective a little bit about search on
all of this we said earlier that one of
the objectives people have oftentimes
around the content marketing program is
search engine optimization that that
desire to go higher up in the rankings
of organic search and the reason for
this is Googlebot loves great content
it's one of the things that Google has
optimized on in terms of search is
looking for that right highly resonating
content so Googlebot looks for great
content if you've got great content out
there then you're going to have the
opportunity to get people back to your
site and on that topic of great content
we've talked about it has to be audience
relevant but has to be authentic
authentic content is what's going to win
and it's going to win from a search
perspective but it's also going to win
with your target audience some people
fall into this trap about I was just
getting a lot of content out there this
goes back to that guiding principle it's
about quality content so just because
you get SEO traffic doesn't mean it's
good traffic be sure that your content
appeals specifically to your target
audience
avoid that temptation to write too much
than content just to get that morality
going on provide meaningful resources
for buyers in each stage of your sales
funnel so think about the content your
target audience wants the audience
that's important to your business write
that and you're going to win with that
audience and you're also going to win
with SEO okay top content marketing
metrics I'm a big believer that you have
to measure everything at some point
someone's going to come back and say so
how's that content marketing investment
going how's that program going not to
mention you yourself want to use that
data to understand what content is
resonating what is it that is going over
with that audience so you can do more of
that unless it's something that's not
working so here are common content
marketing metrics we use out there it's
about the web traffic the number of
visits that you get this is can be
either because you're driving them
therefore
lead generation perspective or you
notice an uptick and what traffic visits
because that content is out there given
freely as an inbound marketing tool it's
about the views and the downloads on the
content itself lead quantity if you're
driving towards an outbound use of
content for lead generation lead quality
super-important that goes back right
content authentic content relevant
content to the audience conversion rates
how many of those leads or how many of
the people that come to the website
actually do something further either on
the website or as a prospect social
media sharing are people out there
really giving your content to the people
that they care about and then like some
Plus Ones always a valuable measure so
important to know what your metrics are
you're going to count and actually go
through those then finally I'm a big
believer at always understanding what
the challenges are out there because we
understand the challenges that you can
work to eliminate those challenges from
your own program so these are the top
challenges that are facing content
creators probably not a lot of surprises
here but content creation can become too
time-consuming alright so think about
that five-step process and think about
how you can make sure that you keep it
moving so it doesn't become too
time-consuming not enough content for
their use cases alright so that means
you have to get creative can a bunch of
people in a room that you know from the
company that also think big and help to
have them help you come up with what the
right content will be content is not
entertaining or helpful well that gets
back to being a good writer you can make
content if you have the right content
topic you can make it something that
people want to read poor content
integration across the marketing effort
all right this is why we put that
strategy in place this is not random
acts of content content for good this is
about making it part of the strategy
lack of a content marketing budget well
we talked about those four sources of
content get creative you don't have to
have a lot of money to do content
marketing that's why it's such a great
tool think about how you could
crowdsource your content think about
what content is out there that you could
curate and then finally all about
production
and not having the knowledge or the
training
well again you can attend webinars like
this get started a little bit lots of
articles out there on content today
don't let that be a barrier so think
about those challenges so when you put
your program together they're not
challenges for you alright content
marketing in a nutshell you got it we
started with demand creation and what
that's all about it how content
marketing fits into both the inbound and
the outbound parts of that we moved into
talking about how you actually go
through and put a content program
together and then we talked about
important things in the end like
measurement and making sure you meet
those challenges I hope that was super
useful to you and go out and put a great
content marketing program together
alright let's jump into some questions
first question I have here is what is
the best way to solicit content from
customers there's a wide gambit of
tactics that I've used that I've seen
used successfully
first of all probably the one that's
most commonly leveraged is that personal
relationship that you might have either
you as a marketer or maybe there's
someone on the product team maybe it's
someone in sales where you have poor
customers that you know have done great
things with your product or you're
offering that personal relationship can
be huge so I would say one of the first
ways to solicit content is leverage the
relationships you have in the
organization to be able to really go out
and talk to the customer and ask them
for their support and their help another
way that I've seen it done that's been
very effective is if the company has a
blog amazing like customers should you
like to tell their stories customers do
like to share their best practices
there's this innate nature of all of us
as humans of wanting to share of wanting
to give back to folks so if you have a
blog or maybe a newsletter some vehicle
that you're reaching out to your
customers that's also a good vehicle to
say hey we're looking for customers that
want to contribute we'll help you with
the writing if you'd like to write it
we'll help you with the editing but
really putting it out there that you
know our product or service better than
anyone else out there we would love for
others to benefit
from your knowledge so using vehicles
that you have for communication and
asking people is another way to do it
also if the company has events or user
conferences that they involve customers
in oftentimes the last customers to
speak that actually can then become a
great source of content again one of the
beauties of content is use it over and
over and over if there's a presentation
that a customer is given at a conference
maybe it's not even your conference
maybe it's a third party conference see
if you can't leverage that bring it back
in by the way slides and PowerPoint
presentations were note with notes or
another great vehicle for delivering
content or you can take that content and
bring it into some type of a story so a
third vehicle I've seen very effective
is if you have events or their third
party events where your customers are
presenting could be best practices could
be their own customers story then that's
a way to find out and leverage that
content as well so those are three tips
that I would suggest that you leverage
by the way always remember key and
content marketing is this is not salesy
you don't want a customer to say oh I
have to tell you this company is
wonderful they treat me wonderfully I
love this company because they're
wonderful that will not be authentic
that will turn people off what you want
to capture are things like best
practices real facts and statistics
about what that company has done with
your product or your offering all right
another question here when your content
has the objective to improve awareness
in this particular case about sleep
quality would you recommend that doctors
with that specialization write or edit
it and if so how do you keep property of
it and separate dr. brand from your own
breath wow great complex question first
of all it does vary by industry on what
level of expertise you need to have
involved in terms of the writing or the
editing so I would err in areas that
involve health personal fitness type
areas that there is a lot of involvement
from the experts now it doesn't mean
they have to write it themselves you
could actually take the notes write it
for them have a third party come in and
write it but I would make sure in areas
like this that you actually go to a
source that has that right training
because at the end of the day
someone's personal well-being is there
in the mix in terms of editing I always
find that valuable I do it with
engineering teams as well as step out of
the world of health care or medical
conditions even in software I'll put
something together but I want to make
sure it's really right I'll go to an
engineer and ask them to edit it I'm not
looking for him to put the commas in the
right place or her to put the periods in
the right place I'm looking for them to
give that feedback up did we have the
right accuracy here in it in terms of
separating the brand that's a big
strategic question on the one hand you
may want that doctors brand to be
directly aligned with the brand of your
company because that gives you
credibility that says hey here's a third
party or a physician that really knows
the space and they're buying in on us in
fact it's generally harder to get people
to do that but if you don't want those
two together then that has to become an
upfront discussion you need when you're
soliciting their input to put the
content together to be very upfront
about the company brand needs to have
priority and as they're going to work
with you or not work with you on that so
hopefully that helps you on that
question
here's next one Jason Miller at LinkedIn
has suggested producing one larger piece
of content and breaking it up into small
pieces for distribution do content
pieces need to be wholly separate or can
I reuse and repurpose content pieces
great question
let me start with the latter first one
of the beauties of content marketing is
reuse so the reality is look for every
way that you can get creative in terms
of reusing that content repurposing it
maybe it takes different form factors
maybe it starts off as a great webinar
and then finds its way into an
infographic maybe it starts off as a
great white paper and finds its way into
a webinar so I would always look for
creative ways because as humans we also
learn differently
some people like video format some
people like reading because it's more
conducive to the way they learn and or
what their time schedule is some people
like things in an infographic because
it's quick fast information so it's good
to use content in different ways not
only because you get that Ryu
but also you may get different audiences
reading it in terms of breaking it apart
I think you can do that I've been a part
of campaigns where people where I'm
actually the consumer of the campaign
and they've said and here's chapter one
tune in next month for chapter two and
in the next month you'll get chapter
three for me it tends to be more is this
useful to my customer at the end of the
day does my target audience want to
consume it that way or am i putting them
through torture for me that this once
you get one chapter next one to get the
next chapter is a little bit more
torturous my mind is in it I want to get
into it now so I don't think it's a
wrong guidance to break it up into
smaller pieces but you need to think
about your target audience how they want
to consume it what's going to work for
them what is good for them versus
potentially annoyance so think through
how your audience wants to receive it
now it is I think a great strategy if
you write a whole piece of content on a
topic but then you keep adding to it
because your knowledge is deepening
you're learning new things so that
actually you're able to continue people
coming back as okay I want to learn the
next piece of information you've
discovered so another part of this is
thinking about you know when you talk
about writing one larger piece of
content does it have natural breaks that
you can mark it as very natural breaks
love this one I've been a small startup
with very limited resources how can I
incorporate content marketing into all
the other responsibilities I have well
the good news is you have a lot of
responsibilities so at the end of the
day you're going to learn so much about
marketing and probably so much bad sales
and so much about customer support and
maybe even so much about engineering the
product that when you decide to go to
that next company opportunity discover
your own company you will know so much
so goodness is working in a small
company great personal benefits in terms
of your own self learning but there is
that idea of resource constraint and
totally get what that can be like having
come from smaller companies at different
points in my career so I think this gets
back to getting strategic and also
getting very creative so from that
strategic perspective
really thinking about what content is
going to have the most meaning to your
customers you don't have incident
resources you don't have to publish
weekly maybe for your audience once a
month is enough but come out with the
content that's going to be most
important to them also go back to that
idea that we said there are four sources
of content see what you can crowdsource
see what you can get contributed because
that takes a big piece off your plate
you're not having to do as much research
now you're really bringing things
together you're editing it you're
pasting it together is having to do all
the writing yourself looking at the idea
of curation
is there content out there you can pull
together in a useful format for your
particular audience also syndication
there may be people out there that have
content and that you can negotiate a
pretty good price if they're behind what
you're doing to actually release their
content so think about your different
sources of content think strategically
what's the best content going to be and
then I would also add into that that
process we talked about you get those
five steps down the first time it's
going to take longer than the fifth time
really keep to that process and that
will become a much more streamlined
faster process for you internally but
the reality is you're in a great spot
learning is so key when you're in a
small company and you're going to be
able to leverage everything that you
learn into your next company
all right you mentioned for Googlebot
the content has to be great content can
you clarify what we need to consider to
make it great in the eyes of Google what
I would do is first take a step back and
say yep Google is a consideration in any
search engine is a consideration and we
reference Google because it is such a
prominent search engine out there in the
in the lecture but I would first
recommend take a step back and think
about what is great content in the eyes
of your customer because if you answer
that chances on our Google BOTS going to
like that content as well so make sure
that you first think outside in what's
going to be that relevant authentic
content that your particular target
audience is going to want now coming
back to our friend Googlebot Googlebot
is looking for things like have you
taken your keywords and just shove them
all over that piece of content Googlebot
doesn't like that
if you want to rise up the in terms of
SEO organic search for come up with
something automobiles and that every
other word in your piece of content is
and you will like this automobile and we
think that automobiles are like the best
thing out there since automobiles and
all it appears to be is keyword stuffing
then Google BOTS not gonna like that so
we'll avoid that what you really want to
do is make sure you're honing in on the
topic of interest another recommendation
would be and this was in that quote we
went through make sure it's not too thin
it needs to be rich content it needs to
make a point it needs to have good
information in it adding images into the
content can also be of use because they
help illustrate what you're talking
about
avoid content that really doesn't say
anything and trust me I've written
content that looks like that and it's
really bad bad for your target audience
doesn't do much for you in terms of
search so really think about it from the
perspective of your target audience
right well for them
and chances are Googlebot is going to
like it as well but also follow the
general best practices of search engine
optimization things like dodging keyword
stuffing is not going to help you so I
think we have time for one last question
we've been getting many many questions
from you so thank you and we
unfortunately will not be able to answer
all of them but one last question that I
found interesting is around the brick
and mortar how does this all apply to
more of a brick and mortar type of model
ah yeah great question so a couple of
things this is all very top of top of
mind it is equally valuable to brick and
mortar and let me give you a couple of
the avenues first of all people have to
find you if you're a brick and mortar
establishment they're going out there it
is there I'll give you an example right
now I'm looking for a new camera and
I've been researching different small
mirrorless cameras and I'm out there now
looking for where I can buy this
mirrorless camera and who I'm going to
feel is going to be the better company
to work with on this not in terms of the
manufacturer but in terms of a camera
store a brick-and-mortar camera store
add the ones that are also giving me
tips on the best way to use them
Arlis camera pros and cons of mirrorless
versus traditional cameras lot of the
mirrorless cameras believe it or not
done have view finders so you're having
to use all on screen which is really
hard in the bright sunshine people that
are giving me best practices around how
to use these new smaller cameras so when
you think about it even if you're a
brick and mortar you have to find ways
to bring people into your store and the
web and marketing online is a very
valuable source of that and again if you
go back to the original things we're
talking about people trust content they
don't necessarily trust advertisements
we've been in the camera business for a
hundred years
well that's nice how do I know you've
really been in it for a hundred years
but if you're giving me content that's
useful to me I'm probably going to grow
a preference for your store over someone
else's so that's one Avenue the other
Avenue is in store so now you've got
someone that's come into your
brick-and-mortar store maybe it's a
sports enthusiast store if you have
content there that people would be
interested in people that are interested
in a particular sport again that's going
to draw them in wow I am having an
experience now it's not just about going
in and buying the thing it's about
everything else you're doing to create
that experience and content can be a
very valuable part of that experience
home appliances this is getting fun
think about a home appliance store you
know if I walk in and you've got recipes
they're free for me to take with this
brand-new appliance thing that's going
to be a better experience for a yeah I
definitely I learnt how to use that
right steamer because look I have five
things now I can make with it
that's content marketing it's helping
drive people to have a preference great
question thank you thank you so much so
I hope you all enjoyed this webinar as
much as I have I certainly recommend
that you again go to our website to
check out the different courses that we
offer including Linda's courses on
marketing please visit us at create
stanford.edu so please have a enjoy the
rest of your day and we hope to see you
in our next webinar